حقق مشروع النقل العام للحافلات في
المنطقه الشرقيه خلال اشهر قليل ارقام
كبيره في عدد الركاب بحسب ما اعلنته امانه
المنطقه الشرقيه حيث بلغ عدد الركاب اكثر
من 20000 شخص منذ منتصف اكتوبر الماضي
وستعدادات المستمره لتوسيع المسارات
الحافلات وتجهيز المحطات على اعلى مستوى
عبد الرحمن العصيمي
نقله كبيره يشهدها مشروع النقل العام
بالحافلات في منطقه الشرقيه بعد انطلاقه
قبل اشهر قليلا لنتعرف على ابرز ملامحها
[موسيقى]
هذا المشروع يشمل ثمانيه مسارات هذه
المسارات تربط مراكز النمو ونقاط الجذب في
القطيف والدمام والظهران والخبر بطول
اجمالي يزيد عن 400 كلم للذهاب والعوده
مسارات المشروع للنقل العام بالحافلات تضم
واثنتين 10 محطه للركاب موزعه على جميع
المسارات وفقا نطاق الجغرافي لكل مساج
عدد الحفلات يصلوا الى سبع وسبعين حافله
كل حافله يبلغ عدد مقاعدها 35 مقعدا هذه
الحافلات تتقاطر على جميع الخطوط بمده
زمنيه تتراوحو ما بين خمسه عشره الى 33
دقيقه اخر الاحصائيات تقول ان اعدادا
الركاب منذ بدايه تشغيل التجريبي في
اكتوبر الماضي حتى قبل ايام قليله وصل الى
اكثر من 200 و30 الفرح
يستطيع المواطن والمقيم في منطقه الشرقيه
حجزا تذكرته لركوب هذه الحافلات عبر تطبيق
ذكي للهواتف المحموله يستطيع من خلاله
المستفيد حجز التذاكر ومعرفته ومسارات
الحافلات وكذلك اقرب حافله لموقع امانه
الشرقيه بدورها اكدت ان تطوير قطاع النقل
العام بالحافلات هدف استراتيجي للامانه
حيث سيساهم في سهوله الانتقال داخل المدن
خاصه لغير القادرين على تملك او قياده
المركبات الخاصه عبد الرحمن العصيمي من
المنطقه الشرقيه العربيه